the golden knights were back at the
fortress last night and fans were
treated to yet another win yeah we're
used to that by now right so the
knights hosted arch rival san jose the
knights broke out their retro red then
they broke out their dominating four
max pacquiao ready open the scoring in
the first period
right there is mark stone adding another
goal in the third and then with about
eight minutes left to play
mark andre fleur here's the breakaway
here's evander kane and there's mark
andre fury join sparks
a poke check to save the game golden
knights win two to one
that was sick i mean
the dude is just the man i don't know
what else can you say like
me and rebo were talking about we want
to buy the rights to a movie about him
i don't think this movie is going to be
any good just
i should just cancel that right now but
it's flattering
very flattering yeah i think it can make
a movie you just call it the flower
so the knights are going to play the
sharks again on wednesday at t-mobile
arena we can just call that the sequel
and then the golden knights head to la
to take on the kings as vegas looks to
keep control
of the west division mark andre fleury
has always been an aggressive goalie
alex
he's always he's good with using his
stick sticky passes the puck very well
and that poke check on evander kane
uh quite dramatic i know it and he's so
humble
he's like no no one's gonna watch that
no we're all gonna watch that he's also
by the way one of the best pranksters
in the nhl just fyi